NARRATOR: Infidelity, Nazis, and
strippers?
[gasp]
These are some of
the most scandalous
royal marriages in history.
An estimated 750 million
people worldwide tuned in
to watch the union of England's
Prince Charles and Lady Diana
Spencer, which slowly
collapsed under the weight of
tabloid gossip and infidelity.
In 1993, British tabloids
leaked the transcript
of a racy six minute
conversation between Charles
and an old flame--
BRITISH MAN: Oh dear.
NARRATOR: Camilla Parker Bowles.
The scandal was
dubbed Camillagate.
Diana would later
admit to her own affair
with a British cavalry
officer named James Hewitt.
Charles and Diana
divorced in 1996.
A year later, Diana
was tragically killed
in a car accident in Paris.
As for Charles and Camilla,
they finally married in 2005.
And in a final nod towards the
controversy of their coupling,
Camilla is referred to as
the Duchess of Cornwall,
not Princess of Wales.
The love story of
Dutch Princess Beatrix
and her German suitor Claus
Von Amsberg had a rocky start.
When news of their engagement
became public in 1965,
so did Claus's past.
As a teenager, Claus was a
member of the Hitler Youth,
and later served briefly
with the German Army
during World War II.
Scarred from five years
of Nazi occupation,
the Dutch people bitterly
opposed the union.
But Queen Juliana,
her husband, Prince
Bernard, and Dutch
parliament approved
of the princess's fiance.
The 1966 wedding went ahead
as planned, sparking a wave
of violent street protests.
Claus worked hard
to revamp his image.
He denounced the Nazi regime,
learned Dutch, and steered
clear of controversy.
He eventually became
the most popular
member of the Dutch royal
family until his death in 2002.
Edward, Prince of
Wales, officially
became King Edward VIII when
his father died in 1936.
Just months into
his reign, Edward
popped the question
to his girlfriend,
a divorced American socialite
named Wallis Simpson.
BRITISH MAN: My word.
NARRATOR: The proposal set
off a major crisis in Britain.
As king, Edward was the head
of the Church of England.
To marry a divorcee
violated church doctrine
and was considered politically
and socially unacceptable.
BRITISH MAN: Oh heavens.
NARRATOR: With no
hopes of a solution,
Edward decided to give
up the throne for love.
In December of 1936, he
abdicated his royal duties
to his brother,
the Duke of York,
who became King George VI.
Edward and Wallis married
in 1937, becoming the Duke
and Duchess of Windsor.
The 1950s wedding of
American actress Grace
Kelly to Monaco's
Prince Rainier III
was right out of a fairy tale--
lavish, elegant, and
very highly publicized.
But their rebellious
daughter, Princess Stephanie,
was another story.
Stephanie was no stranger
to shocking headlines.
She was in the car during
the accident that killed
her mother, Grace, in 1982.
In the '90s, she ended up
falling for her bodyguard,
Daniel Ducruet.
His previous girlfriend
was six months pregnant,
but that didn't stop them from
going public with their affair.
The couple lived together and
had two children out of wedlock
before marrying in 1995.
[wedding march]
The union was reluctantly
accepted by her father,
Prince Rainier, who
insisted Ducruet
sign a prenuptial agreement.
It was a smart move.
One year later, just eight
weeks after their first wedding
anniversary, paparazzi
caught Ducruet cavorting
in the buff with a stripper
at a private estate
outside of Monaco.
The couple divorced
shortly after.
The Duchess of Alba
was one of Spain's most
flamboyant and richest
women, worth as
much as 3.5 billion euro.
She lived by her own rules.
She loved bullfighting,
flamenco dancing,
and flaunting her unique style.
The 85-year-old
sent tongues wagging
in 2011 when she walked down the
aisle with a much younger man--
[gasp]
Alfonso Diez Carabantes, a
straight-laced civil servant
24 years her junior.
The romance outraged
her family, who felt
Diez was only after her money.
To placate her heirs and
prove their love was real,
the Duchess released
her will early,
splitting the bulk of her
fortune among her six children.
When the Duchess died in
2014, Alfonso was left
with nothing but the memories.